this probably isn't going to go on for
very long since we did every game of
every World Championship not really so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
a de facto World Championship not a de
jure a world championship because my
Latin isn't very good right Arjun yeah
sergeant degrees now what I mean is the
winner of this match was declared the
world champion later but they didn't
know that at the time or maybe they did
and this was the match between Karpov
and coronary 1974 now of course they
played World Championship matches in 78
and 81 not to tell you that but this was
a semi this was the finals to see who
would play Bobby Fischer don't go
jumping at home with the right answer
and well Fischer wasn't going to play
because he was busy he actually had a
good reason for not playing he had just
gotten a new house and he had to move in
and you know his new house was it was in
crazy town okay and so he was busy
moving into crazy town and Fischer made
a hundred demands and then when they
were all met he made a hundred more so
it was clear not only was he not going
to play the match because of the crazy
demands but it was also clear because he
didn't play chess anymore most people
who are Fischer defenders because we
need some of those people out you know
they like to say old Fischer was very
reasonable okay well Fischer won the
match in 1972 and then he didn't play
near 80 games in 72 73 or 74 and he
still used to be a really active
champion so he was active I guess in his
own mind anyway so since it was clear
Fischer wasn't going to play whoever won
this match between Karpov and coarsening
would be the world champion now one of
the games for this match is very famous
I'm sure you all know it we could just
skip over it but I'll show you anyway
because Ken West was quite insistent and
then I'll show you a game that I didn't
know about which was at a Petrov defense
which was also quite exciting
what's interesting about this is this
was Game two of the match the famous
dragon game so now you all know what I'm
talking about
and Game six was a Petrov
so I guess course Roy couldn't fix the
dragon so later they made a movie about
this match which would have helped
scorched eye at the time called How to
Train Your Dragon but they didn't have
it out then so terrible
okay so Karpov was white up lady for
over the years
Karpov decided that efore wasn't working
very well against Garry Kasparov they
started playing d4 more but in the 70s
Karpov mainly play d4 and they played a
dragon and when you think of a dragon
Sicilian you normally don't think
Anatoly Karpov right in fact you guys
are probably thinking what's the dragon
Sicilian okay but well people like just
say white wins by force black wins by
forest because people like saying stuff
like that these are the same people who
hang a queen every move okay and then
they give you their opening expertise
right Arjun yeah Archer degrees okay now
Karpov often would play classically
against the dragon he would Castle
kingside
he'd buy Bishop e2 and Bishop e3 or
Bishop e2 and Bishop g5 and then just
play sort of boring because he's Karpov
but in this game Karpov made it clear
that he's from the streets okay he
probably was working with dominique
mayer even though dominique what wasn't
born yet so hey Dominique okay so Bishop
e3 f3 and Queen d2 the so called
Yugoslavia TAC and this is the way
people try to refute the dragon nowadays
although because Spartak played the
dragon in a World Championship match
more than once and Carlson's played the
dragon so you know with people like Joel
playing the dragon back there obviously
it's sound okay so castles Bishop c4 now
the other move that's very common
nowadays is too long castle and after a
long Castle black had decide to play d5
now d5 is not recommended unless you're
playing me the
I recommend it okay okay so Bishop d7
and h4 you can Castle first but usually
they transpose rook c8 the bishop on c4
isn't the safest so Bishop b3 and
probably the latest theory is to play
the quote-unquote salt this variation
closed quote where black plays a very
early h5 okay and course and I played 95
at night c4 and one reason this isn't
very popular now is because of this game
where of course should I got destroyed
so people were like I only getting
destroy I want to play better so most
people don't let white play h5 they try
to play h5 themselves and block the
kingside up and that's completely
different variation and occasionally
I'll do some secret illegal preparation
and I'll prepare to have black and a
dragon slash accelerated dragon and I'll
have some novelty ready but otherwise
I'm not playing this consistently the
American player who in the 80s and 90s
played the dragon all the time was don't
all say it at once
have a seat at home you don't know you
so you didn't see the movie How to Train
Your Dragon you probably saw it too
right yeah that's what I thought
come on somebody knows Chris where it's
an American yeah which American and the
80s and 90s played the dragon every game
with black what do you guys do all day
you're gonna work all right the correct
answer is Sergei Kudrin okay and he
still plays it today and that's right
well actually you know people think that
all the the Russians like were super
GM's that came over here but actually uh
Kudrin was like 1600 when he came here
so he actually got good here now Kudrin
as you well know in the in the 83 84 us
championship I think 84
five he played in the u.s. championship
and with black got zero out of eight
so maybe the dragon isn't as good as we
thought okay he played the dragon in the
Benoni the two safest openings you can
play all right now after it takes takes
white plays h5 if black plays h5 then
white doesn't play h5 unless white
sacrifices all his pawns burrs okay and
course noise like numb yum-yum-yum-yum
and then g4 and the knight goes back
obviously white has tremendous
compensation for a pawn by having the
open H file now again if you analyze
games from the 1970s with the eyes that
we have now in computers and opening
theory maybe the moves aren't the best
although Karpov moves are the best and
just to show you how strong they were
everybody in the world is 2700 now fact
only see there's three people in this
audience who were 2700 feet a that's how
easy it is to be 27 nowadays and Karpov
was 2700 1974 that was very rare in fact
there were times where there were no
2700 players now if you're not 2700 you
know you can't you kick invite any
tournament you can even give ID to the
US cadet right arjun okay that may have
not been right okay and Karpov played 92
which is not a move that would appeal to
the people of this audience or the
people at home okay at 92 was a
defensive move making sure black never
gets counter play one of the main ideas
for black and the dragon is to sacrifice
the exchanger on c3 and try to open up
White's King obviously if that Knights
defended by another night that's that's
not going to do anything okay and also
this Knight can sometimes come over to
the Kings side and help out with an
attack but mainly 992 is for defensive
purposes now occasionally
white can also play e5 and now that
there's no knight on d4 we have some
pressure on the D file and often white
plays e5 and after it takes g5 would win
a piece because the knight on f6 is
defending the bishop
okay course should I play Queen a5
karpov played Bishop h6 that's the kind
of move you guys like and there's a lot
of analysis some of it black sacrifices
his rook on f8 with Bishop h8 and in one
variation he lets white play Bishop
takes Bucky he played Bishop takes h6
and generally I'm in favor when I have
black of having my opponent's Queen move
away from C 3 and C 2 so I can get some
counter attack and occasionally get
checkmated that's that's life right so
that you get recommended right ken west
then I said sometimes so that's okay
so coronoid played rook F c8 and just
looks like a typical dragon game both
sides are checkmating each other and if
you play and accurately you could lose
quite quickly okay now again Karpov was
the master of defense
even when he was checkmating you very
impressive
okay and he played the move rook to d3
which is a famous move now because most
people when they're Queen and Rooker on
the h-file they're not thinking defense
game now in 1974 they also weren't
thinking arby's see with our B's around
74 mm what you agree it was it just as
bad then Wow now as a vegetarian that's
the only roast beef I can eat there's no
meat in it yeah so I can actually eat
Arby's okay so rook to d3 man it's hard
to sacrifice on c3 when white keeps
defending it how am I supposed to
sacrifice on c3 that's not fair okay so
Karpov not only checkmated you he made
sure you didn't check meet him okay rook
c5 the idea is I don't want white
playing e5
I don't want white playing g5 I protect
everything no attack for Karpov and
Karpov resigned because you had no
attack Arjun you agree
yeah yeah so you have no interest about
your own King just your opponent's so
yeah
okay so let's play like Arjun and see
what happens
probably the computer will break so ok
g5 and I assume 9 h5 was the idea right
and then you wanted to play Knight f4
and then I'm going to I'm going to take
your knight and then you're going to
meet me okay now remember black played
Queen a5 rook c4 Rick's CAA why do you
think he did that yeah so should we do
that yeah you don't mind do you
ok good ok
were caged - that's the safest I mean I
don't want to be mean and take your
night but I think I might be mean and
take your night I might be I don't know
if I will be though I think I could be
mean some other ways - nothing I could
take it let's see do I get made it or
I'm safe where's Laurence Olivier what
yeah well betters uh yeah being nice
okay I mean those of you on YouTube with
your engines can tell me why a whites
winning here okay so instead of
undefended c3 which he painstakingly
defended with 92 right okay he played
rook d3 probably is gone oh it is there
no no route d3 that's a lot the move
can't be made also there's a variation
they give with Knight f4 with your idea
this is this isn't me this is the
variation that the annotators point rook
takes c3 Queen takes c3 rook h2 stopping
mate yeah this is our variation by
transposition okay so they agree with us
okay so what happened Queen c3 is gone
now a rook to e3 there we go okay so
Rick g3 safe rook c5 g5 anyway that's
not very nice okay so black played rook
c5 to prevent g5 and white played g5
what's the word I'm looking for on speak
English ken west disheartening thank you
he didn't say happen that were that's
very disheartening when you stop a
moving your opponent plays it when your
opponent's free had 2700 it was like ken
west who played g5 guy he didn't see
where g5
but if car pop plays g5 I'm like oh I
just stopped that move it he played it
anyway okay course Knights hook he's
like I just stopped g5 what are you
doing okay now things are defending
other things and things are happening
rook d5 now that's interference right
okay and if Knight takes d5 White has
meat into with Queen h7 Queen h8
so he didn't play 1996
see how that works Arjun so what did he
do see his Queens attacked his rooks
attacked hmm or takes d5 Knight takes d5
so again Knight takes d5 isn't good
because queen mates on ha8 on the other
hand what's white threatening hmm if you
trade knights on f6 and black takes with
a pawn his King has an escape although
this seems to win a lot of material okay
so caution I played rook e8 and now this
isn't mate because after takes takes
Queen h7 the King runs out although I
don't think I like black there alright
so he played Knight f4 it's got two
knights one for each of you this ship c6
e 5 Karpov the brilliant tactician you
all thought he was doesn't make any
sense okay why it's Karpov so good this
isn't fair okay so the idea is we're
blocking the Queen from coming over here
so they probably give the variation but
no they don't okay so the variation I
see in my head which is probably wrong
but if you're watching at home just
ignore this part okay if he takes it
looks like I can take and play Knight h5
I don't see anything wrong with that now
we're threatening me and night hears
made and if you take this looks like
whites better right okay and then
obviously mate and if you don't like
that you could do this mate okay so e5
is a real good interference a lot of
moves this game of interference so as
you can see White has a lot of attack on
blacks King and black has no attack on
White's King usually in a dragon if one
side is attacking the other side's
defending and there's no attack for
there sorry that's not good okay so
coronary played Bishop takes Knight this
doesn't work as we just saw obviously
Knight takes Knight keeps falling for
the same to move mate I keep telling you
who eh seven Queen h8 okay so you play
the [ __ ] takes Knight takes and even Ken
West is like ooh hoo I see it
ok Queen g7 mate probably that should be
stopped
takes check here and now Queen h8 check
and coronary resigned the variation is
king e7 and now if you play rook e1
check Queen takes rook is a good answer
that'd be a good one minute game rook e1
we take sori one mate yeah ok so you
play Knight takes bishop first and now
if you play Queen takes Knight then rook
e1 check just wins because you're
waiting the rook on the a it and if the
King moves everything wins depending on
where the King moves and so of course
you I resigned so after that game people
decided that opening the H file was good
for white and then they usually started
playing h5 now that game is quite well
known and I don't think you could
improve on car pops play the next game I
I didn't know and the boys still can't
improve on his play now I gave a lecture
I don't know if it was here or if it was
in Charlotte but it was on this opening
and there was the game Evon Chuck Anand
we are Anand won in like 20 moves of
black and a Petrov and it was this
variation
and black played very aggressively with
96 and f5
okay and Anand with black got a massive
attack against Yvonne truck sacrificed
all his pieces and one very quickly okay
but this ain't Yvonne Chuck this is
Karpov in 1974 now this was game 6 of
the match and it's clear that course joy
in his seconds hadn't fixed the dragon
yet so they played the petrov this is
actually very funny to me one of the
best players over the last 25 years
Boris Gelfand he's known for playing two
openings with black against efore the
night orb Sicilian very sharp and the
Petrov and also he started playing the
sveshnikov sicilian so it's funny to
play what's considered the most exciting
openings in the Sicilian and then play
what's considered the most boring in the
petrov but actually the reason is golf
and does a lot of preparation so in
those openings he knows many variations
past move 20 and so with the petrov he
was drawing easily against players of
his own rating and when he was paired
two players slightly lower than him
maybe twenty-five twenty-six hundred he
would play the night orphans fashion
akov and beat them so course joy who's
playing the dragon sicilian and playing
a very sharp game and getting out tactic
by Karpov now plays the petrov but plays
a very sharp way and blacks creating a
lot of weaknesses the black is being
very aggressive the knight on e4 is good
the bishop on g4 is good although these
pawns are weak maybe the knights going
to get into e6 maybe this they'll get
into e6
or d5 and you know black could get into
trouble okay so Queen b3 and if I'm not
mistaken I could be this is still the
the Avant Rokinon game that the black
one and twenty moves ok and Korchnoi
sacrificed his be pawn and said I dare
you to take that pawn Karpov called over
the arbiter and said he's talking okay
and the arbiter said no talking all
right so
oh well if you play Queen b3 and you're
tagging the b-pawn and the guy doesn't
defend it then you should take it
Karpov played Knight d2 because Bishop
f3 would have been annoying and after
King h8 he took on b7 and I don't think
this is what Ivonne tricked it I think
Yvonne truck retreated his Queen to c2
which I didn't get well he lost in 20
moves so maybe back to the drawing board
for Yvonne truck okay um this is a
problem when you start labeling things
okay you call Ken West a grandmaster and
then you look at his rating and you get
confused okay so when you label people
yeah sometimes the labels don't fit
usually it does usually Grand Master Ken
West makes a lot of sense
now the Petroff people like with a
Petroff that's the most boring opening
ever well sometimes it is and sometimes
it's like this where it's not boring at
all where people are sacrificing
material and then both sides sacrifice
material of both Kings are exposed so
chess can be boring if you wanted to be
scary or you can make it really exciting
okay that's up to you excuse me bless me
okay so rook f6 defending the knight on
c6 preparing for a as gen shotty would
call a rover moving the rook up and over
other players would call it a rook lift
and attacking White's King Karpov didn't
like the oncoming attack so he resigned
well I hope you enjoy no that's not what
he did okay Karpov played Queen back to
be three not liking his Queen on b7 very
much of course it was blacks move black
could play rook b8 and after Queen a6
there would be a nice discovery with the
rook on f6 so Karpov was like 9 and no
tricks for you okay rook g6 now there's
a saying we have in poker called all-in
okay and that's what black is doing
black sacrifices a pawn black has a bad
pawn structure but he's all-in he's
going to attack the white king and if it
works he wins if it doesn't work then he
has a lot of issues
and probably at this point in the match
course I was behind so you got to win
some games otherwise you're always
behind okay and this is the the thing
about chess that Fischer didn't like one
of the many things was if you're playing
a match with a limited number of games
let's say 8 or 10 or 12 if you're ahead
one game or two games you just draw the
rest and you and you win the match so
you may have to take some extra risks on
the other hand if you're forced to win
six or ten games the match could go on
forever and you don't have to play like
a lunatic hoping to win a game and catch
up and of course matches are a fixed
number of games for a lot of reasons one
is some venues can't hold a tournament
for you know five months so if it's
first to win ten games and after five
months it's six games to five people
start saying well you know come on okay
so usually if it's 10 12 14 games you
know when the nancial is going to end at
least okay so Rick g6 blacks going on
the attack blacks playing very
aggressively even though it's a petrov
Bishop back to e2 defense and now with
the bishop on each soo this knight can
safely move probably to f1 if the knight
moves otherwise Bishop f3 is quite
annoying
so he defends the knight some more
Bishop h4 this this piece configuration
of the knight on e4 and Bishop on h4 is
exactly how an on be Devon Chuck notice
the f2 pawn is attacked rook f1 and it
looks like black has a tremendous attack
for a pawn problem is not only is black
down upon but is structure here isn't as
good because his pawns aren't together
like like Karpov has sort of a nice pawn
structure and so in the long run White's
going to win bike has to checkmate white
or win some material if nothing happens
over the next ten moves white has an
extra pawn and a good pawn structure
which may not be enough for some but
that was Karpov bread and butter went
upon consolidate when the endgame so of
course surely has to prove that he has
an attack and that's not easy to do you
don't have a force to win you have to
sort
keep building so he played Bishop f3 and
played a very forcing line which didn't
work Knight f3 Bishop f2 and Karpov took
of course and now white is up a
tremendous amount of material to bishops
for a rook okay I had a dream last night
I had two bishops for a rook but I knew
it wasn't possible so I woke up I'm like
nah this is a dream I've never had two
bishops for a rook okay in fact even
though black took the pawn on f2 White
was already up upon and this is actually
a problem a lot of my beginning students
have when they sacrifice 300 pieces
they're like oh I can went upon and I'm
like that's not you you can't you can't
decide to win material when you've
sacrificed a lot of material you have to
check major opponent so even though he
got a rook and a pawn for his two pieces
since he was already down to pawn black
has a totally losing material disparity
here of two pieces for a rug but he was
hoping that White's King would be
exposed and he could take advantage of
that later okay Queen d6
now he's coming to get him oh that's
pretty scary
he's scared Arjun I'm scared Queen g3
I'd be scared of that I want the guy to
play Queen g3 that's annoying and one of
the reasons the top players are the top
players is not only do they play force
twins when they have them but they see
their opponents threats and ideas and
they prevent them and lobbyists if it
was blacks move after Queen g3 I
probably take black that's a big attack
other Brooks coming 8 okay so 9 g5 which
not only stops Queen g3 but threatens
Knight f7 I hate when that happens I'll
try to attack my opponent they're
attacking me
okay so rook f8 preventing Knight s7 and
the rooks obviously better on f8 that is
on a a for attacking Queen a3 does black
want to trade Queens no because then
black would resign to bishops totally
crush a rook especially if the grand
especially when the guy has no pawns
even with upon I wouldn't matter here
but okay so course noise trying to get
his Queen in here to attack the White
King but he can't move forward because
then White has an attack so we can't
trade Queens and we can't play Queen h2
so back to d8 what you wanted to do and
Bishop f4 blocking the F pawn and it's
clear to me that there's just nothing
here again the Queen and rook are
attacking the knight on g5 but the
Queen's overworked sort of like me and
if we take all these pieces here then
Queen takes rook has made okay so the
attack is stopped White has two pieces
for a rock and looks like Karpov is
going to play Fischer for the World
Championship okay so h6 and the knight
safely goes back to f3 and there's no
attack here and one of the reasons is
black's knight on c6 isn't doing
anything so course joint went all-in and
he was rebuffed and because of games
like these and games mainly from the
1800s we learned if you sacrifice a lot
of material you have to accurately
calculate that you have made or a
winning attack or when your material
back because if you don't you're just
going to say where my material go and I
don't really blame Korchnoi of course
should I had black and he was behind in
the match so you got to win so it's
unfortunate now that's one of my best
excuses normally I try to draw all my
games and if I win I go to the arbor and
say no no I drew okay I get lessons from
Geary by the way anyway so I was playing
here he's Schulman in the last round of
a tournament an open tournament and if
we drew we both won about four dollars
they might have been like three dollars
and 90 cents but if we won then we went
over $1,000 so even though I had the
black pieces instead of playing my usual
trying to draw every move I played the
kings in the
i sacked everything and then I resigned
okay so I tried to win but trying is the
first step to failure and he won and he
tied for first the tournament and people
were booing until their throats were
sore okay so rikiei
but okay there's Karpov - good Bishop d3
and he again he doesn't give up
riki for trying to mess the game up
because two rooks is just too good for
for two pieces it's just too good for a
rook but maybe he can confuse his
opponent so of course today was a very
inventive tricky player and maybe if you
take the rook black will get some attack
g3 and Karpov said something very
interesting related to this idea of not
taking the rook which I also wouldn't
take he was playing a match with Anand
for the feed a world championship and
Karpov was two pawns up and an on
sacrifice two piece basically for
nothing and Karpov didn't take it even
though computer would have taken it and
they asked Karpov why didn't you take
that piece and he said I'm up two pawns
that's enough I don't need any more net
right he was right he just won with his
two pawns so here two bishops for a rook
that's enough if there's a way to avoid
counter play where there's no threats
that's the Karpov method so after g3
it's hard to see black doing anything
like breaking through or doing anything
after Bishop takes rook pawn takes
there's Knights attacked on f3 if the
knight moves the black Queen can come to
h4 I could see a possible attack there
after g3 I don't know I don't know what
black would do okay so Rick f6 I guess
you want to play g5 Queen c5 does play
g5 Knight takes g5 Karpov simplifies
into a much easier winning endgame now
that blacks King is exposed and while
blacks running out of pawns and his
pieces are pinned and attacked yeah
every every black piece attacked and
and okay in well I would even argue that
White's ahead material White has dish
ap'to pawns for a rook actually White
has two bishops and two pawns for rookie
tonight and if I had to pick one I would
always pick two bishops and two pawns
forgets the rookie tonight but here all
of black's pieces are pinned and hanging
for example if it was White's move
I guess Queen takes Knight is pretty
good and Bishop takes either rook is
good so every move wins for Wyatt black
played rookie six defending everything
rook e1 this pieces blacks only good
piece it's defending this it's defending
this so he wants to get rid of that and
once the pieces are traded and we have
Queen and Bishop versus Queen and night
you'll notice that white has two extra
pawns so that's unfortunate
and he played Queen to GA probably the
simplest way to win after rook takes
rook is just to trade pieces and White's
up two pawns for nothing so okay so he
played Queen g8 that's the trickiest H
for defending his great Bishop again we
can't play rook takes rook now because
Bishop takes rook check and then we take
the other rook then White's up a piece
so he played rook to g6 question yes
yeah maybe I should do this I mean the
truth hurts I was assuming didn't of a
perpetual but now I know you'd have a
virtual wow I like this variation that's
what I'm going to play yeah also I guess
I have lots of other ways too well
that's a pretty good way to way okay so
instead of rook takes rook played rook
to g6 rook takes rook and now black
decided to resign well there's two moves
that makes sense right Queen takes and
rook takes Queen takes I go check and I
don't like this for for black although I
don't see it I don't see an immediate
win
maybe I don't play check it's hard not
to because I like it so much
yeah probably he would check as he's
Karpov and Karpov would probably take
this knowing him you could instead of
Queen takes f5 yeah I wasn't sure what
to do do what but he takes what check
this is this would be risky yeah yeah
only works a giveaway well I mean the
Karpov I know would like this endgame
for Wyatt
and then if rook here I have g4 and this
is a fairly easy win because we have
thousand extra pawns and two bishops and
pass pawns and rook takes seems like I
could take this and if you pinned my
Bishop again I don't know here then g4
and then one thing that's very strange
about this game this night never moved
it never could move there was never
anything good to do with that Knight
just sort of in a bad square of course
we don't want a blunder and play
something like Queen takes d5 because
Ricky to check would be annoying
followed by Queen takes Queen so well
probably a premature resignation from
somebody who was not happy but it extra
reminds me of the game Karpov be Topalov
where he was also down in exchange but
had four extra pawns and that he won
pretty handily so here with basically no
pawns left and no defense to his king
course I resigned and well after six
games it was clear he was going to lose
the match and again
this is a world championship match
lecture although this match was de facto
the World Championship match because
Fischer defaulted and if I want to do a
real easy lecture I could lecture on
that match Fischer Karpov okay then I
just showed empty chessboard and
that would be it actually I was at a
match where somebody didn't show up and
they what they want anyway
test is hard okay and that was the match
Korchnoi Kasparov 1983 they played in
Pasadena course they showed up because
Maariv didn't and the arbiter was Colton
ASCII and Game one was a forfeit because
because prophet didn't show up and
Colton asked he said I don't want to
come here every day and forfeit cos far
off match over and Korchnoi being in
Pasadena during the US Open which was in
Pasadena played in the US Open and tied
for first with Larry Christianson I
think ten and a half out of twelve I
remember correctly might have been 10
that was the strongest US Open ever at
about 25 grand masters Sarah Wan played
Korchnoi Christensen and Benjamin
everybody played I was an expert at the
time and feed a decided ad that doesn't
count
let's play a match for real and an 84
they played the match in London and
course I said ok I'm guessing of course
they refused I'm not sure they would
have done because of course she already
won the match anyway they they played
course I won the first game with black
and that was it then Chris Moore of
showed why he was Kasparov so I guess
you could not show up to a match and
still win but it's not easy
only Kasparov can do it very impressive
so car block was very impressive in the
70s and there are some people who aren't
me that they're not me but there are
people who think that Karpov had good
chances against Fischer and 75 and that
I can't believe this but Karpov in the
early 80s they thought was was better
than Fischer in 75
I didn't play either one of them so I
don't know but I do know that Fischer
won 20 games row against GM so that's
reasonable and Fischer was 20 75 feet a
when nobody else was like over 26 50 so
and that's I mean it's hard to gain
rating points where there's nobody near
your rating
so I'll bet on Fisher but yeah and 75
Fisher would have beaten Karpov probably
would have been more interesting if
Fisher never quit chess and played
Karpov in 78-81 those would have been
interesting matches but okay Karpov a
little too good for course knowing this
was the first of their World
Championship matches and then they
played for the real world championship
twice later once was a very close match
where Karpov was ahead five to two and
lost three games in a row making it 5 to
5 and the winner would win six and
Karpov won the next game so he won six
to five and then later he won six to two
pretty easily and by that time and
during those matches course there was a
lot older than Karpov and obviously past
his prime but well this was a great
match courtly in his prime and Karpov
almost in his prime in 74 close and
playing great chests and it's too bad we
didn't see Karpov fischer but it's an
alternate universe they play we just
have to go there all right and hopefully
we'll have more world championship
lectures but not too much longer because
we're almost done with every game that
would just make it up matches all right
see you guys next week
you